my name is tom keichuk i'm a
distinguished engineer at dell
and today i'm going to be talking about
streaming video analysis and rust using
g streamer and prevega
freight is an open source project that
i've been part of for a long time
and this is our experience
using rust this isn't an introduction to
rust talk but
is just us sharing our experience and
hopefully providing some
lessons that will be useful to all of
you
so let me find the problem we're trying
to solve in this
that brought us on this project first
our goal was to build a streaming video
service that could be deployed
that could be deployed
to a data center or to to a customer and
they would be able to have many cameras
going in
to
uh
to it and and be able to
do analysis on those videos in real time
so doing things like object detection
seeking
and have this all sort of
scale up to large numbers of video
streams and
have good good performance
example of what that looks like is
here's nvidia's deep stream
running on a live video stream so this
is a generic object detector and it is
detecting that there are cars on this
highway
this is a very sort of basic application
but you can imagine much more
sophisticated ones being built on top of
an architecture that supports this
uh to do this we relied on an
application called gstreamer which is
uh it's been around for a very long time
it's a pipeline-based framework for
chaining different processing elements
related to video and audio processing
together
it is
it is most commonly uh it was originally
and and most commonly done for
client-side sort of processing work but
uh this is now scaled up so it's more
generic and plugable uh and there's you
know over 2000 plugins for it so this is
sort of an ideal uh
technology to build upon
so there
there have been several existing
approaches that people have tried um the
the most obvious of which is sort of a
batch architecture right like you can
imagine you know you write one day's
worth of video data into a file in s3
and then you perform analysis on it
through some hadoop job or something
like that uh it's a very common uh
paradigm
um the the obviously trade-offs of that
are latency and dealing with recovery in
the case that your device that's writing
that die is midway through um
sort of the the traditional solution to
that has been to look sort of smaller
size patching um so this is the natural
transition that people have had from
moving to hadoop to things like spark
where you're we're going from you know
large batch of you know a day to small
batch of you know
a minute
um this still has this still has a bit
of latency which may not be an issue for
for many applications like one minute of
real time one minute to within one
minute of real time is probably
acceptable to a lot of applications
but failure recovery is still
complicated especially if you're dealing
with things pipelined and potentially
out of order within within that right
but if you also think about it it sort
of messes with your data format um one
thing that we actually saw customers
doing was was people were
encoding video by grabbing every frame
re-encoding it as a jpeg sending the
jpegs through kafka and then re
extracting them out on the other side
with with the time window reordering
them into the appropriate time and then
re-encoding it as video
this is an awful lot of code and it
destroys your compression ratio and it
ruins you know what would otherwise be a
nice format and
dramatically escalates storage costs
because you know kafka is obviously
going to be storing it on what need to
be high performance drives and we'd like
to be storing you know months if not
years worth of data
so we want something
that that does better than this
and we want something that's just a
truly streaming model from the beginning
that that treats recent and historical
data uh as uh as contiguous
and you can move between them uh just by
just by reading it um so to do that we
really want to do is we want to
lean on object store as our long-term
persistence we don't want to try and
scale up and have local storage on all
these nodes because well you know cloud
storage is cheaper right and if you if
you're only worried about archival data
that's what you want but to do that
through the same api is a little bit
tricky
similarly
we want to have easy recovery to just
have a point in in time oh you failed at
this point you can resume from that
point so the the notion of atomic
atomic rights is very important
and to be able to like declare an end to
data like i only want to retain data for
one month and have that data disappear
after one month while at the same time
uh not screwing up your format like if
you just set a retention policy on s3
and say oh throw out all my data after
one month well
your format better support that or
whatever you're using to do indexing
better be aware of that so we want
something that sort of automates all of
this
fortunately
that exists already and it's called
brega
that that is exactly the use case that
prevego is built for and it does all
these things very well
uh the basic architecture is as follows
uh you're you're writing data in it goes
to provega
and readers go read access goes through
prevega whether it be real time or batch
and purvey is in the background
interfacing with your long-term storage
whatever that may be hdfs you know
a cloud store whatever
and it's intermediating those calls but
providing a streaming interface and
real-time access and atomic rights and
all that good stuff
so you you just operate on the
abstraction of the stream
the other advantage that brings to the
table is scalability i need to explain
this graph a bit this is a test that we
did just to demonstrate um scalability
in terms of number of writers so here
uh the the throughput is in you know two
gigabits per second which is very modest
and something that all of pervea cockpit
pulsar can easily handle from a single
source what we did is we scaled up the
number of sources while holding the data
rate the the total data rate the same so
when we go up to 10 writers each of them
is writing one tenth as much data and
100 writers one 100th as much data so
this is just demonstrating what happens
when you scale up the number of sources
independent of the actual data rate and
as you can see
um you know pulsar like literally
collapses and kafka is barely any better
it just it doesn't hold up to a large
number of writers concurrently whereas
purvega is only interested in your data
rate and if it supports it then it can
support it and if not
so an end-to-end pipeline looks
something like this you have a camera
that's producing some data it's
extracting into a video stream
then you run some derivative algorithm
on it in this case uh we're doing a
nvidia gpu based object detector who's
out outputting some json
and so we have a modified stream with
you know bounding boxes
and then we have additional like
metadata that can be put off to the side
for analysis with like a splink or spark
application
uh here is a demo of that
so here's
assuming this plays
maybe
unable to play video
well great
the whole point of pre-recording this
demo was to prevent exactly that uh
anyway this is
if that played it would be a live demo
of uh this working through web ui with
multiple video streams jumping back and
forth between them fast forwarding
rewinding
and showing object detector working and
labeling things and then piping that
into a uh
a uh
a um
a uh
flink job which was which is uh which
was allowing you to to run queries
against it um with a sql-like syntax to
produce graphs showing how many cars go
by on a highway
uh so we wrote wrote this in rust
and
uh
that's sort of an uh interesting
decision because why would we do that
right um there there just weren't a lot
of rust users and no none of our
customers were asking for for a rust
that wasn't a priority
um
but we still think this makes sense or
at least at least i do
and i think this comes down to something
that we came up in a talk a while back
by
brian cantrell and he talks about the
idea of platform values the idea that
software and languages have certain
values that they bring with them
and that people who use those software
are going to be attracted to those
values and build on those and those
and they will get stronger in those
dimensions not every piece of software
is going to have all of these values
these are just once he identified but
not every piece of software is going to
have all of them because when push comes
to shove you can't right
certain ones are higher priority for
different types of applications and
different types of frameworks and
naturally
those applications and frameworks are
going to prioritize what's important to
them
so if you look at those he he's sort of
identified of these 10 that he
considered rust's values but i would i
would sort of group these into into
three sort of personas
there's this one we hear about with
performance safety and security but i
think there's also a second and third
one this interoperability integrity and
robustness and then
composability extensibility uh
expressiveness and rigor
and all of those you can sort of
visualize differently
the usual approach that everyone talks
about and the one that gets the most
attention is this performance uh plus
safety and security um and the reason i
think that gets a lot of attention is
because it's very hard to do
uh in in a lot of other languages
so this is a graphic that came from the
google android team
uh where
they're talking about like where do
where do you have ex security exploits
it's when you have unsafe code that's
not sandboxed and running on an
interest-worthy input but sometimes you
can't you can't change the fact that
your input is untrustworthy and
you don't want to have a sandbox for
performance reasons and so that leaves
you in a tight spot where you want you
may want for those same performance
reasons that you don't want to put a
sandbox on there to not use your c plus
plus but there aren't there aren't a lot
of options that have extremely high
performance if you really care about
getting every last ounce of out of power
out of your cpu
and this has been repeated many times
for example
amazon's firecracker which is the kvm
that underpins
aws
google's
virtual networking infrastructure that
they run in their cloud to provide each
each
user with their own
virtual
uh virtual network
uh
the the facebook cryptocurrency dm
russ tls is a clean room tls
implementation similarly trust dns uh d
full and ndns stack uh tor the anonymous
web browsing agent uh
one password has their stack implemented
in
in rust for this reason uh servo was a
classic one that is a chrome renderer
that would you know they wanted to have
it be higher performance and add
multi-threading but uh couldn't do it in
in c plus plus because the uh the
overhead
like the security uh risk of of running
something that's as complex as css and
rendering it in nc plus plus was was a
was a problem and since they did that um
chrome and microsoft edge have also
rewritten their css renderers in
in
rust
tikv is very much the same story and
wasmer is also a very interesting one
that mirrors the css story where here
you're you're wanting to execute uh
webassembly so you have a full-blown
language and and you want to
containerize it but you don't want to
have a very high performance cost
because everything is going to be it's
going to execute on every single cpu
instruction
um so those are those are all great use
cases and if you find yourself in that
boat by all means rust rust is an
excellent choice but that just wasn't
our choice that wasn't our problem
our problem was much more basic than
that we didn't have a performance issue
because we were going to be network
found anyway
we didn't have a
security like extreme concern because
well we're dealing with trusted code on
both sides of the wire
our problem is that we we're dealing
with a stateful client and to understand
why
you need to think about recovery which
is if you imagine you have a client
connects to a server
it sends data the server can track where
the client is
and when the connection goes away it can
tell the client oh you left off after
that point and it can resume and
resend the same data
but this means that the server the
client code can't be code cogend it
can't be just automatically generated
from from a template or something and as
soon as you say that you you're going to
have a client with state that you're
going to manually write well it makes
sense to start offloading a lot of other
things to the client as opposed to
putting them on the server because you
can do things more effectively and
efficiently and by the way your cpu
usage isn't centralized
so what we ended up with was a client
design that looked like this where we're
implementing a core client
implementation once and then we're
writing bindings for each of multiple
different languages that connect to it
so that we can interact with that same
client library so that we don't have to
write the client logic over and over
again
so this is basically doing what's called
f5 foreign function interfaces and there
a different set of values matter which
is the second set from
of of rus personas where you're
concerned about interoperability
integrity and robustness
and understand why
f5 can be fairly complicated you need to
think about things like calling
conventions alignment uh is the memory
garbage collected in one or both
languages can the objects that are
returned contained references to each
other and
when gives the data freed uh is is there
a particular allocator that's used uh
what about error handling
um are there other restrictions on
threading for example python has a
global interpreter lock that you need to
hold before you execute any code in
python
there are os specific
requirements in languages like go for
example
and character encoding oftentimes
different languages have very
opinionated
views on what a string looks like that
may differ from one language to another
and so aligning these on across language
bases is not necessarily as
straightforward as it seems
and i think this is an area where rust
really shines
and understand why i think it's
important to look at a method signature
if you look at c here we have a fairly
generic method it's just right and it's
writing some heights but what's going on
here we have
two parameters that must agree with one
another and if it if they don't it's a
bug right so that's already like one
sort of oddness
and then we're encoding an error in a in
a number in in the in the return value
go improves on this a bit
uh
uh
wait and memory management of course is
just through documentation because you
don't know whether the caller or the or
the callee is supposed to free free that
buffer
go improves on this a bit
uh by including the length into the
parameters so those are unified
having a separate error value so it's
not encoded into the normal return value
that's useful
and the memory management is done by
garbage collection which is certainly
better than than relying on
documentation and human effort but
can be difficult to work with on a
cross-language basis
if you've ever tried to get the
go and python garbage collectors to
cooperate with one another when handing
objects back and forth between them
you'll understand why
compare this to rust where
rust has errors that that can't be
ignored unlike like by accident unlike
the the go
code there it has um compile-time memory
management which is an interesting way
to do it because it's not it's not
garbage collected but it's also
uh
not not manual in the way that that c is
um it's
has very explicit contracts uh for
example here this this this first
parameter it's dictating that this is
safe to pass between threads and can be
evoked concurrently for multiple threads
and here it's very explicit about what
the semantics of the buff are
that it won't be modified that it will
not be retained or any pointers retained
to it after the call returns and it is
the responsibility of the caller to free
the buffer
this is amazing and exactly what you
want when you're dealing with
cross-functional language because you
can put across language functions
because you can put the specifications
that you want into the method signature
very explicitly and have them enforced
in fact this is so ideal that people
have automated it
here's uh three frameworks this is pyo3
which automates calling from python neon
which does the same thing for node.js
and helix which does the same thing for
ruby an example of what this looks like
in your code is if you wanted to call a
function from python you can annotate
the function py function and import pyo3
and that function will be callable for
more than python with no extra work on
your behalf
so it really is a dramatic improvement
in terms of the ability to operate on a
cross-language basis and this is made
possible by the the explicitness of the
function signatures in the language
so what lessons did we learn when we
were doing all of this
the first
the first that's very interesting i
think is thinking about ownership
ownership is a very central concept to
rust but doesn't appear explicitly in
any other language
but i think i would argue that it is in
other languages
and that it is implicitly in most other
languages so here i've written some java
on the slide here
and
there's two alternative methods here for
processed foods that
process them in different ways the first
first step in both of them is to sort
the list of them
and this is done in two different ways
one in case it's put into a tree set
which is a sawyer collection and by
adding it to it it will implicitly sort
them
and the second is by pro calling sort
a standard library function on the list
itself
now
these differ in ownership
and this concept exists in java because
these are semantically different in the
following way
if you were to inside of the the first
function there
grab an element from that
the the sorted
set
and then modify it
in such a way that its comparison
changed with respect to other elements
this would violate the invariance of
tree set
it would
render the internal ability of the data
structure to function uh
it
it would it would it would just cause
assertion errors or any number of other
problems inside of tree set and you
wouldn't be able to predict accurately
what it's going to do because there's an
implicit contract on tree set which is
that when you pass items into it that
the collection now owns them
and similarly in the process foo's
example the collections.sort method is
not owning the data that's passed into
it the assumption is the caller retains
ownership and so if the implementation
of collections.sort would be modified in
such a way that it for example handed
that the list off to another thread and
then in the background called sort
concurrently
that would break the invariance of the
caller and
in in both cases if you weren't aware of
the any change that would alter the
implicit assumptions about ownership of
the function signature
or go against them would result in a co
in an error in once on one side or the
other
so this is so this concept really does
permeate
um
the the next interesting thing that we
encountered was
that russ just doesn't need the visitor
pattern it's all over the place in our
java code and the to understand
like consider when you're doing request
reply it's very straightforward because
you end up with a bunch of different
types and you have something that has an
interface and you say okay well now i
need to process these but you probably
want but your processing code is almost
certainly type specific so you end up
writing something like this where you
have this reply processor and then each
of your possible replies you have a
method that is a one-liner that just
calls an overloaded method
on the object that was passed into it
so this is definitely not ideal
um but it is it is what you sort of live
within in job in c sharp
rust has something which is
perhaps boring to everyone in the
functional programming crowd but is
absolutely amazing for somebody coming
from java which is that it has a news
where
the the individual elements of the news
have member variables that are specific
to them just like an object and
this is just amazingly better because
you can replace
hello with
the or the
the hello implementation up on the upper
right with the hello reply and any
fields that it has can be simply fields
in the in the new and this allows you to
replace this
this mess with with something much more
straightforward which is just a match
statement
um
the other thing i want to throw out
there not because it's rust specific but
because it's just such a great pattern
and i i really want to see everyone do
it everywhere which is the notion of
using the type system to enforce
invariance so here's a great example
right
instead of having like a user and a
boolean on it like whether or not the
user is authenticated we really want to
have authentication be
something that's validated right and so
a good way to do that is to embed it
into the type system by separating a
user in an authenticated user into
separate objects and then having using
visibility rules to have the one and
only one way to
create that user to be the authenticated
user to be to call authenticate passing
in a user
another example of the exact same thing
would be to do it with request and
authorized request
but this pattern is a great way to
ensure a happens before a relationship
that you can type into a method
signature because you can say oh this
this method takes an authorized request
russ definitely goes beyond this though
and you can use the same sort of pattern
where you where you're leveraging the
type system to enforce additional
invariants
this is a good example of one here we
have a connection pool and it has a get
connection method unsurprisingly
but this connection object has this
interesting parameter at the end
uh the syntax is a little uh obscure but
what this is doing is it's saying that
this connection cannot outlive the pool
that it came from
by definition the connection must be
closed before the pool is closed you
can't close the pool first and then the
connection in it be left alive and then
potentially error or whatever would
happen otherwise so this this prevents
that sort of runtime
consideration from even having to be
brought up because the situation is
ruled out at compile time
another way this can be done is with
ampersand mute the classic thing this is
able to do is to use for exclusivity uh
but we we found it very effective as a
way to impose ordering requirements or
ordering ordering semantics
so here's an example where where uh we
have a writer object that takes a self
as a mute so when that is um invoked
that
that write method by definition is
ordered with respect to all other calls
to that right method
so in the case where we want to impose
ordering semantics of say writing to a
stream we can say okay well the rights
go and the stream go in the order of the
right invocation which is by definition
defined because this method signature
mandated that it was semantically
defined
so yeah this can really be leveraged
um
sort of
the one of the classic problems we face
is is one that exists in basically any
um application that's like managing
connections and multiple requests
concurrently
which is you end up with this notion
where you say okay i want to have
multiple requests going over the wire
and i want to have like multiple things
coming back over the wire so you end up
with this situation where you have some
sort of state about like what's going on
that is being accessed from both sides
from from both the top and below from
from replies coming back from the server
and from from data coming down from
above and this gets very messy very
quickly
it's it's a little bit it's a little bit
hard to deal with
so much so that people have built uh
patterns around it
the the classic example is is uh actor
frameworks where you have a what reactor
pattern
um
where you have a cue in front of it you
have an actor who's running an event
loop and that gets a state and an update
and then applies that update and does a
transition
and that's a much easier model to deal
with uh except you know it has the
problem that you know you have to buy
into a framework and you have to code to
a specific
uh specification and it it really has a
way of intruding on your code
in addition to introducing runtime
overhead
um what we discovered we could do it
with rust which was
sort of remarkable is that you can do
what i would call the the async reactor
pattern
where you replace the queue with an
async rendezvous queue
the channel with with an asynchronous
channel um
rendezvous channel is a channel
essentially with zero capacity where
you're handing off from directly from
one thread to another
now
with async await uh the way it works in
rust is that futures aren't real uh they
aren't like a completable future in java
or c-sharp they are um sort of done in
the background via polling mechanism so
when you wait on a future it's actually
transferring
it's as though you're as it's though the
actual physical thread is being switched
to another one
so an async rendezvous channel
does nothing it's essentially a stack
switch uh behind the scenes it looks
like you're you're working with with two
with two distinct threads but there
aren't two distinct threads it's just
two distinct code paths and if you
combine that with a state which is just
you know in a new you can write
essentially an actor framework and about
12 lines of code
and
this is all just normal code out of the
box nothing fancy you don't need a
framework and there's no overhead right
you can just do your async block have a
loop pull on your channel and then
decide what you want to do based on the
state in the channel and this has
defined ordering semantics so you get
all the niceties that you would with an
actor framework except there's no queue
so there's no overhead associated with
it there's no you know state transition
or locks or or anything else and
because rust futures are zero cost this
all compiles away into nothing it's as
though you wrote the perfectly optimal
like
like candle every possible state code
except you didn't have to write it that
way
um so it's it's a very it's a very neat
pattern
um
but we came to love that we
didn't choose rest for but but but
really came to appreciate later was was
this this third persona that i outlined
which is this composability
extensibility expressiveness in rigor
what that resulted in is a lot of
um libraries and crates that were
published that are just really great
that they have very clear apis they're
very explicit about exactly what they
expect and how you can interoperate with
them how you can extend them and how you
can work with them and they're extremely
well defined and they're very by virtue
of having such a clear definition i've
been very carefully crafted to do it do
what they say extremely well and so we
were just like whereas in virtually
every other language i've worked in
adding a dependency was
like
horrible and avoided at all costs
because you're like well maybe i'll just
write it myself because i don't want to
take on this other thing and be worried
about it that just isn't the case in
rust and we have great experiences with
our dependencies first and foremost of
these is certi
certi is by far the best serialization
framework i've ever worked with in any
language uh you have you define
uh your object just as you normally
would and you put two annotations on it
serialize and deserialize
and it does the rest um it can support
all of those formats and it does so
out of the box and generates what the
code you need on demand with no separate
compilation step uh
and best of all you can define your own
format which is what we did we wrote our
own format and there was no code that
was per object per format at all which
is absolutely wonderful you can just
define what it means to write an integer
to the wire and certi takes care of the
rest
i i wish every language would emulate
this because it's such a great
experience
um here are some other other
tools we found super useful um feel free
to like
snapshot this i i would absolutely
endorse every single one of these crates
uh they were they were really useful and
and uh i have nothing but positive
things to say about them um
clippy rust format and docs are all
built in and
um i would i would uh strongly encourage
everyone to run them as pre-submit
checks because they just they just do
everything exactly what you want uh
tracing is a great way to get uh logging
and uh things automatically inserted
into logs snafu for error handling um
etc
um yeah
can't say enough about how great rust
libraries are
so what we really came to love at the
end was also the borrow checker which is
the thing that everyone says you're
going to hate and that you're sort of
geared up to fight with but
it did something that i expected which
was that we no longer had to think about
thread safety we were writing in java we
spent you know 20 to 30 percent of our
design time thinking about how do we
design this to be absolutely sure it's
thread safe and that we won't ever have
any errors and we have to you know how
do we structure our components such that
we can easily validate that it is
correct at code review time
and so that's a huge time sync and you
spend a lot of time focusing on it and
thinking about it and i was really
looking forward to working in russ where
we just would not think about it
but what i
i didn't anticipate was not only would
it save us that time
but it would change the way that we
wrote code
because when you no longer have to worry
about that suddenly
the things that you contorted your
design around to try and like make sure
that it was provably correct or that you
could convince a human that it was
correct just weren't there anymore
because you could lean on the compiler
to do that enforcement
and that allowed you to do designs that
that you just wouldn't in other
languages because you you had more
freedom and you had more power to sort
of
leverage
some other aspect that you were
concerned about to try to make uh that
better
so
with all of russ personas i think they
they're sort of about one thing you know
there's sort of three different ones but
i think at the end of the day they're
all really about empowerment and that's
why i love it
thank you
[Applause]
so so let me
let me see if i understand the question
the question was how do we uh manage the
data in a distributed way such that uh
we're we're trading off chunk versus
chunk size versus latency
yes
ah okay so so normally if you suppose
you had an object store and you were
writing to it sort of naively and
directly right it won't let you read
back the data that you've until you're
finished writing it
so if you're writing you know
data for an hour into a single file then
your latency is by definition at least
an hour
vega doesn't have that issue you can
write to provega and then read the data
like within a single digit milliseconds
uh and and have a live feed directly off
of provega in the meantime for vegas is
going to batch that up into a very large
object and put it into your object store
but
like just because it didn't arrive in
your object store doesn't mean you can't
read it and it's still durable as soon
as povega acts it which is within again
single digit milliseconds so um
is able to do that you know in very very
fine-grained you know uh individual
rights which are guaranteed to be atomic
and then as soon as they're acknowledged
back the the the writer can forget about
them so the writer's buffer is is only
like you know a couple megabytes
um and it's just that's that's the
writer's buffer for the case of you know
failures or something went wrong with
the connection or whatever but um
in general if everything's sort of up
and we're running fine like
the end and latency will be very low
because it it's it's it's going to be
read by the reader before it's actually
hitting the object store
[Music]
you